Solo dos días después de que un misil
norcoreano sobrevolar a Japón piong
young lonso otros dos misiles hacia el
mar del este la sexta prueba de
armamento en 12 días esta vez fueron de
corto alcance según las autoridades
niponas que no escondieron su ira Corea
del Norte especialmente desde este año
ha estado lanzando repetidamente misiles
de una manera nueva a un ritmo rápido
desde finales de septiembre en este
corto periodo ha realizado seis
lanzamientos intensificando sus acciones
directas y provocadores Corea del Norte
justificó El hecho como un ajusta
represalia por los ejercicios militares
entre Washington y seúl de hecho en
medio de las tensiones Estados Unidos
desplegó al portalónes uss Ronald Reagan
uno de los más poderosos de su flota que
ya entró en agua surcoreanas el
miércoles el consejo de seguridad de la
ONU se reunió para debatir posibles
soluciones adicionales contra el régimen
de Kim jong-un donde estados acusó a
China y Rusia de apoyar a Corea del
Norte
la República popular democrática de
Corea ha disfrutado de la protección
general de dos miembros de este consejo
estos dos miembros han hecho todo lo
posible para justificar sus repetidas
provocaciones y Bloquear todo intento de
actualizar el régimen de sanciones Pero
según los dos países Estados Unidos
envenena El entorno de seguridad
regional
el Consejo de Seguridad debe desempeñar
un papel constructivo en el tema de la
Península de Corea en lugar de depender
únicamente de una fuerte retórica
opresión las discusiones y
deliberaciones del Consejo deben
contribuir a la distensión en lugar de
alimentar la escalada esta semana marcó
la primera vez en cinco años que un
proyectil norcoreano pasaba por encima
del territorio japonés Corea del Norte
adoptó una nueva doctrina en septiembre
que hace Irreversible su condición de
potencia nuclear